alors un bon d'anonymous c'est parti
pour un bénin en limousin cette petite
silhouette question question pour vous
je me rappelle que ces réponse par oui
ou par une femme oui bah oui oui magali
lettre vous l'accompagnent ludivine
madame êtes vous la raconte pas lieu de
quelqu'un sur ce plateau mon nom gilles
entassent mais vous sur un chroniqueur
non est ce que vous êtes une célébrité
un peu un peu d'influx rang vous amis
avec l'un d'entre nous donc une
célébrité qua non non pas mais c'est pas
le liera à êtes-vous célèbre sur les
réseaux sociaux oui ah ok est ce que
vous venez pour une chroniqueuse oui
vous avez des rapports professionnels
avec magazine chroniqueuse oui alors
est-ce que déjà maman ah oui et non ah
bah oui alors est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire pour quel gros dos vous venez
exactement il ya un an ou une chromé
cuse ici qui fait des blagues un peu
pourri
[Rires]
la personne en question fait débat
j'imagine qu'il faut que ça cesse oui
désespoir est ce que vous venez pour un
garçon non
j'ai une petite idée est ce que c'est un
candidat ou une candidate de
télé-réalité non non pourquoi est ce que
mes jambes mam aussi un peu connu dans
quels domaines attriste nous y tenons là
des réseaux sociaux est ce que c'est
pour daniel non
est-ce qu'on vous fait des mauvaises
blagues en face à face ou à distance
aller 2 2 et 2
n'avait pas d'idées mais magali ça vous
dirait
ma manière à moi je suis fait pas
beaucoup de blagues si maman était une
belle ambulante
est pourri sinon vous êtes ne s'en rend
pas compte
vraiment rire mes blagues est-ce que
vous saurez est ce que vous êtes venus
pour magali
wilma gagner ce que je vous dit quelque
chose bah franchement
moi je propose que notre invité mystère
viennent nous rejoindre eh oui
[Applaudissements]
à
cela
nous a contactés
sa mère est jeune en peu de temps il
faut que ça s'arrête passé m'a
finalement dit oui aux passagers dit
elle est très jolie ta fier me touche
pas
shawn hamadi ould hamadi il faut que ça
cesse cet enfant est une enfant en
souffrance il n'en était pas être
mauvaise langue chinoise dimaga vas-y
mathématicien raconte-nous alors un soir
mon état à l'hôtel
normal ce cas les biens et puis je
reçois un coup de fil d'un numéro masqué
donc je réponds
bonjour madame
votre impayés de votre carte on va venir
vous enlevez votre canapé chez vous
votre télé mais j'ai pas de carte
et j'entendais derrière maeva rigoler
j'ai une fille taux d'occupation
je suis fan de moi quand je m'amuse je
fais des blagues à ma fille ça mais bon
un fils n'en peut plus bon elle est
surtout non mais c'est pas vrai dire la
vérité c'est surtout un prétexte parce
que shauna avait quelque chose à voir à
quoi vous dire à armagh et sous la halle
et me marier l affaire plus rejeter ni
attention
et wallons mais dans la lumière chez les
basques étaient très jolie tête très
jeune en compte dans la vie mais jamais
vaincu ce mal alors par où commencer
c'est en parle de monolith la semaine
glisse la base'' shonia la viande hachée
dit ma fille ne les écoute pas vas-y
parce que sinon je m a terminé les gens
ou là au caractère les gens ne le savent
peut-être pas mais on vient de vivre
quelques années compliquées entre les
cambriolages ont harcèlement scolaire
qui a été injuste et qui a été un vrai
calvaire pour moi j'avoue que la vie ne
nous a pas trop épargner on peut dire
que depuis quelques mois enfin quelques
années ont dit plusieurs vies dans une
seule d'épisodes catastrophique aux
épisodes merveilleux des fois c'est
beaucoup pour une petite personne comme
moi mais surtout pour toi je suis venu
ici ce soir pour te dire que je suis
fier de toi je sais aussi tout ce que tu
entreprends ce moment et je suis sûr
d'une chose c'est que m'a mis là où doit
être sacrément sur herbe merci tout ce
que tu pour tout ce que tu fais et tout
ce que tu supportes pour nous depuis des
années car on sait que tu ne le fais pas
que pour moi mais aussi pour moi et mes
soeurs au sirop
non
bakar
voilà parce que moi je voulais aussi
qu'on voit cette phase est là de magali
parce qu'on rit beaucoup avec magali
magail ya énormément de second degré
elle accepte beaucoup qu'on la voit
beaucoup beaucoup boutique claire est
vraiment que c'est une qualité
incroyable d'accepter d'avoir de
l'humour et du et du recul bien ma
chérie viens et je trouvais que cette
petite déclaration parce que shauna
avait très envie de dire à sa maman
combien elle était une maman formidable
et combien elle aimait et donc comme
c'est la vérité que c'est la
transparence des coûts ça aussi ça fait
partie de la vérité est qu on est une
famille conduit les choses et ben voilà
donc c'était très chaud
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va j'ai mes déclarations mais
bah oui je sais c'est pour ça évidemment
parce que c'est parfois c'est vrai que
parfois on n'ose pas dire les choses on
croit que parce que on vit ensemble et
qu'on se dit bonne façon elle sait que
je les aime il sait que je laime etc
mais quand on le dit parfois bah voilà
ça fait du bien donc tu meurs
[Applaudissements]